[संगीत]
सो गुड इवनिंग सबको है हेलो
अभी थोड़ा सा 2 मिनट वेट करते हैं उसके
बाद में चालू करते हैं थोड़े से और जान ए
जाए
कोई कहता है लेट आए थे
सो हेलो
है तो इसके लिए आज जैसे मैंने वादा किया
था जिन लोगों ने दे वन देखा हुआ है आज
जैसे मैंने वादा किया था की आज फाइल
हैंडलिंग के बड़े में बताएंगे तो देखते
हैं सबसे पहले फाइल एंडिंग क्या होता है
पहले ये पता करते हैं ये तो जो लिखा है तो
बाद में पढ़ेंगे
मतलब किसी भी कोई अपना सिस्टम करना जब भी
फाइल्स वगैरा पड़ी है
उसके बाद खेलने खेलने इंश्योरेंस की आ
क्रिएट करना उसको मतलब एडिट करना उसके लिए
डालना हटाना फाइल उदा देना फाइल नहीं
बनाना
कहते हैं ठीक है
तो ओपन फंक्शन बैकग्राउंड
तो सबसे पहले मुझे यह बताओ की किन लोगों
को
थोड़ा सा रीकैप चाहिए
कल क्या कराया था वैसे भी कल थोड़ा सा मैं
भी हैवी था तो इसके लिए
ट्राई क्या होता है
भाई बताया जाएगा
अपने कोर्स के अंदर आगे है बताया जाएगा
अगर आज टाइम रहा तो आज भी इन चीजों को बता
दिया जाएगा सो डोंट वारी
से करता हूं मैं इसको आज मेरी डायरी के
अंदर
बने रहो
सब लोग बताया जाएगा
चाहिए तो लिख दो हां कर दो नहीं तो कोई
बात नहीं आगे बाढ़ जाएंगे
की नहीं
देखा था
और सोमवार
स्टार्टिंग से पूरा पॉसिबल नहीं
चला जाएगा स्टार्टिंग से पूरे अगर रिवीजन
करना है तो वीडियो से ही होती है इसके
अंदर मतलब ऐसा नहीं की लाइफ खत्म तो उसके
अंदर वीडियो नहीं रहती वहां पर तो आप
वीडियो से कर वापस कर लो
स्टार्टिंग से पूरा चाहिए तो रिवीजन तो एक
लेक्चर पिछले ही जाएगा उससे पहले के नहीं
होंगे पर जैसे आगे बढ़ते हैं तो पहले का
आते रहते हैं उसके अंदर तो आपको उसमें
रिकॉल हो जाना चाहिए की क्या पहले का था
तो सबसे पहले उधर से मैं इनपुट लूंगा
तो ठीक है बना गया और बढ़ते हैं फिर अब बस
बेसिकली मैं इसका लॉजिक
इनपुट डालेगा अपना आगे का इनपुट डालने का
अपन चेक करें की यार तो 18 से ऊपर है
इंडिया में लीगल देखिए वोटिंग लिस्ट तो
अपने 18 प्लस की है तो 18 या 18 प्लस तो
अपन यहां पर दाल देंगे
18 से 18 के इक्वल हुआ तो क्या करने का है
प्रिंट
यू
मेरा
सो मुझे तो आइडिया नहीं राजनीति का आप लोग
मुझे बता देना किसको वोट करने का मतलब
क्या है क्या नहीं है फिर मैं खुद डिसाइड
कर लूंगा किसको वोट करने का है अगर जैसे
अभी कोई छोटी आगे डालता हूं मैं 18 से कम
वालिया जानता हूं इससे 17 तो बच्चों अभी
तो 17 साल के लोग वोट नहीं कर सकते हैं अब
18 का भी चेक कर लेट हूं की अगर 18 ही
होती है आगे होगा फॉर्म आता है अपना
मैंने आपको इसके बड़े में बताया ठीक है
तो उसके अंदर राहत है
तो मैं अपना नाम
थोड़ा अच्छा लगा चाहिए
ठीक है तो
अपना क्वेश्चन था की बताओ की नंबर नेगेटिव
है या पॉजिटिव है
ठीक है
तो इसको पता करने का एक ही तरीका है
मतलब जीरो अगर नंबर जीरो से ज्यादा है तो
पॉजिटिव है जीरो से कम है तो नेगेटिव है
तो इसमें कंडीशन डालूंगा की आईएफ अगर नंबर
अपना बड़ा है जीरो से
तो प्रिंट कर दो अपना
पॉजिटिव
ठीक है यहां पे देखते हैं ना यह थोड़ा
मैंने फास्ट फास्ट कर दिया है ठीक है
जीरो में नेगेटिव होते ही नहीं है तो उसके
लिए अपन ना एक और कंडीशन लगा सकते हैं अपन
तो उसके लिए अपन एक और एक नहीं लिखेंगे
उसके लिए अपन लिखेंगे
ऑपरेटर होता है जैसे हम लोग इसके अंदर
सिखाया था डबल इक्वल तू के अंदर अपना ये
एक कंपेरिजन करेगा
प्रिंट
जी
ठीक है
बहुत सारे हो सकते हैं ठीक है ना
डिफेंडिंग अपन के अपन कंडीशंस कितनी लगानी
है इसके ऊपर इस पूरे में से एक ही जाएगा
ठीक है तो यह हो गया अपने इसके बड़े में
क्या करना पड़ता है
जब तक अपना जीरो
छोटा है 10 से
ठीक है और प्रिंट कर दो अपने
भाई
को बार-बार
ठीक है
इंक्रीमेंट सॉरी इंक्रीमेंट होते रहेगा
क्योंकि और कंडीशन
नहीं होता है
ठीक है तो यह अपना नॉर्मल वैल्यू से चला
है जो कंडीशन भेज राहत है की अपन ने क्या
कंडीशन डाली है यहां पे कंडीशन डालते हैं
फिर इंक्रीमेंट अपन लूप के अंदर ही इसका
इक्विपमेंट करते हैं एक वैल्यू को चलने के
लिए एक दो तीन कर लाइन तो लगती ही लगती है
ठीक है और अपना एक इजी सिंपल से अपन फिर
आते हो पर लूप के लिए पर
रेंज रेंज क्या था मैंने कल बताया था की
यह उतना ही स्केल बना लेट है यह अपने जीरो
से लेकर 10 तक चलाना है तो चलेगा और
प्रिंट करेंगे
कितने
[हंसी]
इस टाइप मतलब कैसा लगा
और कितना इंक्रीमेंट करना है इसको जैसे
अगर मैं यहां पर स्टेप तू देता हूं तो यह
एक-एक छोड़ के आएगा
मतलब आई में दो एड हो जाएंगे ऐसा रहेगा
फिर ये तू लिखना के बाद में ठीक है
जीरो से लेकर हंड्रेड तक के अंदर वह वह
और आई
परसेंट 7 डबल 20
पर नहीं तो फिर आप अपना
टेलीग्राम पर भी बता सकता
अब वहां पर भी लिख सकते थे टेलीग्राम
मैंने कहा सबका सारे हैंडल्स का लिंक आपको
इस वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में या पिछले
किसी भी वीडियो को डिस्क्रिप्शन में दिखे
जाएंगे
उसके माड्यूल्स कहते हैं कोई भी
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज के अंदर भी पर्सनल
है जो साइन राहत है उसका माड्यूल्स भी
कहते हैं माड्यूल्स क्या करता है
माड्यूल्स डिवाइड करके रिमाइंडर निकलता है
ठीक है अगर मां लो कोई चीज किसी चीज से
डिविजिबल है पूरा जैसे मां लो अगर अपन है
तू से अगर अपन फोर को डिवाइड करते हैं तो
तू करके यहां पर ये फोर तो रिमाइंडर अपना
जीरो आता है इसका क्या मतलब होता है की ये
जो अपना फोर है ये फोर तू से पूरा
डिविजिबल है
ठीक है अगर है तो उसका उसका रिमाइंडर मुझे
जीरो ही आता है
तो उसके लिए यहां पर लिखेंगे की अगर जो
अपना नंबर ए रहा है वो नंबर को अगर 5 से
डिवाइड कर रहा है और उसका अगर रिमाइंडर
जीरो आता है
तो तो ठीक है तो यह वैल्यू हो जाएगी ट्रू
अपनी ठीक है
जैसे इसके अंदर 35
यह वैल्यू अपना 5 से भी डिविजिबल है 7 से
भी डिविजिबल है 735 भी होता है ठीक है ना
और यह 70 भी एक नंबर है जो अपना दोनों से
डिविजिबल है
बस इतना सही मतलब
थोड़ा सा दर्द
ठीक है
सबसे पहले गेम फाइल
डीटेल्स
वो है
वो इसके अंदर दे फाइव डॉट पी ओ एन आपके
फाइल है
ठीक है ना
भेज दो यार क्या हो गया इसमें इंसान है
यार थोड़ा टाइम लगता है
ठीक है अभी के लिए स्टाइल में कुछ दाल
देता हूं हेलो
कैसे हो सब लोग
ठीक
है
फाइल क्लोज करो
दूसरा भी ले सकते हो ऐसे रिस्ट्रिक्शन
नहीं है तो जैसे मैंने स्टार्टिंग में
बताया की अपन एक फंक्शन का इस्तेमाल करते
हैं अपना ओपन नाम से ओपन ठीक है
ना यहां पर फाइल का नाम है
आई आंखें
लिखा है क्योंकि मेरा जो पाइथन का
प्रोग्राम है
तो अगर मैं यहां पर ओन्ली फाइल का नाम भी
डालूंगा ना तो भी मेरा कम चलेगा अगर मां
लो मेरी फाइल कहानी और पड़ी होती तो मुझे
क्या करना पड़ता
है
ऐसा राहत है
है तो उसको वह मां लेते हैं कभी-कभी तो
उसके चक्कर में ये फाइल का एरर भी दे सकता
है इसे दो स्टाइल्स आगे चलने का उसे एक
में सीक्वेंस सीक्वेंस एग्जीक्यूट नहीं
होती है ठीक है ना
नहीं तो फिर यह झंझट नहीं करना तो फॉरवर्ड
ठीक है ना ऐसा दाल दो चेंज करके पूरा तो
बिल्कुल गया नहीं आएगा तो भी चलेगा
आपको कुछ आता नहीं है तो अभी भी कुछ नहीं
है बट ठीक है
ना मोड देते हैं अलग-अलग ठीक है ना इसके
अंदर राहत है एक राहत है आर मोड आर मतलब
लीड मोड
ठीक है ना की फाइल को खोलो रीड करो और जो
अगर आपको स्प्रेड कर लो तो इतना कम अपना
इसमें हो जाता है एक होता है
मतलब अगर फाइल में कुछ चीज पहले से पड़ी
है आपको उसके साथ में नीचे और भी चीज एड
करने की है तो अपेंड से आप उसे लाइन के
आगे और भी चीज एड कर सकते हो अपेंड का एक
और खासियत है ये मां लो अगर फाइल नहीं बनी
हुई है ना तो ये फाइल बनके इसमें डाटा दाल
के भी कम कर देगा
ठीक है ना यह राइट फाइल राइट फाइल क्या
करती है ना की मां लो
की फाइल बनी हुई है और उसके अंदर डाटा है
तो ये ब्लू वाला जो मोड राहत है राइट मोड
तो राहत है वो क्या करता है वो उसे डाटा
को ओवर एड कर देगा मतलब वो डाटा कर जो
आपने नया डाला है वो डाटा इसके अंदर दाल
देगा
तो डब्लू वाले को थोड़ा सा इस्तेमाल करना
है अगर आपको ऐसा लगे पूरा लेटर कहां चला
गया मेरा तो इस आपकी यही गलती हो शक्ति है
क्योंकि इसके अंदर अगर आपको सच में अगर
नया ही चाहिए सबको उसे करो सोच समझ के
ठीक है ना एक एक्स भी राहत है इसके अंदर
एक्स्ट्रा करता है ना यह फाइल बनाने का कम
आता है बट एरर देगा तब जब अपनी फाइल पहले
से बनी हुई होगी उसके अंदर तब ये एक्स
वाला मोड एरर देता है
कौन देखना पसंद करेगा
तो रीड के लिए इस्तेमाल
टीवी राहत है मतलब ये आर के साथ में ही
लगता है या फिर आर के साथ नहीं रहेगा
ठीक है ना टी यह टी क्या इंडिकेट करता है
ना ये तीन इंडिकेट करता है की अपने
स्टूडेंट डायल क्या रहे हैं अपने स्टूडेंट
टैग्स दाल रहे हैं की क्या दाल रहे हैं ये
अपना टी इंडिकेट करता है की टी पर टैक्स
ठीक है ना ईस्ट में बी भी राहत है बी पर
बाइनरी अब कोई भी अगर आपको बाइनरी मतलब
बारी चीज एड करनी है जैसे अपन को इमेज
इमेज अपने डाउनलोड कारी है उसको अपन को
राइट या कोई भी इमेज अपन बना रहे हैं
पाइथन के थ्रू तो पर इस बी का उसे करते
हैं वो बी अपना बाइनरी दर्शाता है की इसके
अंदर बाइनरीज दाल के वो चीज एड कर देगा जब
क्रिएट करना छह रहे हो अपना पाइथन के थ्रू
ठीक है तो अभी अपन बाइनरी पे नहीं जाएंगे
बाइनरी भी थोड़ा सा ऊपर ही लेवल पे चला
जाएगा अभी अपन टी पे टी / डिफॉल्ट राहत है
यह जो आर राहत है यहां पर नहीं भी लिखूंगा
तो ये रीड मोड पे ही जाएगा बाय डिफॉल्टर
इस चीज को थोड़ा सा ख्याल रखना
ठीक है
तो अगर मैं यह जितनी यह फाइल का जितना भी
चीज था वह चीज अब जाकर अपना चला गया अपना
एफ के अंदर ठीक है ना यह फाइल जो कुछ भी
था इसके अंदर चला गया अब अपन को उसके अंदर
देखिए अगर चीज रीड करने होगी तो रीड करने
के लिए अपन सिंपल तब बहुत इजी जैसे मैंने
कहा था बहुत इजी है अपना पाइथन प्रिंट
करना है क्योंकि देखो अपन को प्रिंट करने
का है यहां पर अपना आउटपुट स्क्रीन के लिए
दिखाना चाहिए तो अपन आप प्रिंट कमांड का
इस्तेमाल करेंगे प्रिंट करेंगे एफसी के ना
अपना पूरा फाइल का सीधे चला गया है इस
वीडियो में स्टोर हो गया है इन डॉट रीड
बस अंदर का चीज़ जो है वो रीड करके
बैठ नहीं रहा ठीक है
हेलो है हेलो कैसे हो सब लोग
यह सिंपली जो अपने अपने फाइल में लिखा था
तो मैं पहले
हेलो कैसे हो
कैसे हुआ ये चीज मतलब दो लाइन के अंदर अपन
एक फाइल खोल के रीड भी कर दिए ठीक है ना
सलवार है की नहीं
प्लीज एक बार चार्ट बता दो
चाहिए तो मुश्किल है
तो यह पहले लाइन यहां पर ए जाएगी
यह देखो तीन बार मैंने प्रिंट कराए तो
यहां पर तीन लाइन लिख कर ए गई है
कोई यहां पर एरर आएगा शायद ठीक है
दिमाग में स्ट्रेस लगा
तीन बार तीन बार अपने कर दिया है तो इस
सिंपली रीड हो कर ए गया है यहां पर आप
आउटपुट में थोड़ा सा चेंज देख का रहे
होंगे जब उसके थ्रू रीड कर रहे थे तो मस्त
आराम से एक ही मतलब नीचे ए गया नीचे ए गया
है
तो कम ही राहत है
लेकिन इंटरनल भी प्रोसीजर जैसे रहते हैं
ठीक है अब मां लो की मुझे अपने
को करके देखते हैं
आपका जवाब दूंगा
राइट लिखूंगा यहां पर राइट के साथ यहां पर
लिख दूंगा
की आप लोग को क्या चाहिए
तो देखो हार्दिक केवल उसके आगे आई एम
डिफरेंस इंडिया मैंने गलती से सॉरी
लगा अगर आपको इस नंबर डलवाना चाहते हो
यहां पर तो वह नंबर नहीं लगा आपको नंबर को
टाइप कास्ट करके उसको स्ट्रिंग में बदलना
पड़ेगा उसके बाद में ही वो यहां पर जाएगा
ठीक है
यह अपना थोड़ा
उसके चक्कर
ठीक है यह अपना राइट मोड करता है तो पद
मोड का बताया मैंने कैसे ही अपेंड मोदी था
लेकिन तो अलग-अलग टाइप के अपने फाइल के
लिए रहते हैं इसको अपन लूप्स के अंदर भी
कर सकते हैं और लिस्ट वगैरा
दिखता हूं
अपना एप्स
से होने के बाद अपन ने ये वेरिएबल अपने
प्रिंट करवा दिया ठीक है ना अब अपन इसके
अंदर देखते हैं ये देखो
आप सब कुछ उड़ गया होगा या बैकलेस और आया
ठीक है ना इसलिए आया क्योंकि अपना जो फाइल
था
ये देखो
इंटर करने के बाद नहीं होना मैक्स चैनल
मतलब इंटर
ठीक है
तो ऐसे ही चला है अपना
यह फाइल
एकदम बेसिक से अब बाकी इन चीजों को आप
कैसे उसे करते हो लूप्स आईएफ कंडीशंस
वगैरा उसे कर कर तो वह सर चीज अपने ऊपर
होता है अपन चाहे तो इससे पूरा एक वो भी
बना सकते हैं क्या कहता है अपना
क्वेश्चन पेपर मकर
65 में या फिर जिसमें अपंचा है तो वह भी
ओपन चीज इसके अंदर कर सकते हैं तो फाइल और
लिंक अपना इतना सा ही है इतना सा क्या
मतलब फाइनल नहीं है इतना सा वो तो बस एक
ही कैसे-कैसे क्या करने का राहत है
अगर पानी पी लेते हैं
सबसे पहले अपन एक प्रोग्राम राहत है सबके
कॉलेज में कराया जाता है
उल्टा कर सकते हैं
तो बेसिकली अपनी वेरिएबल
स्टोरी
मैं सोचा की एक बार दाल के गहराई देता हूं
थोड़ा टाइम भी है अपने पास तो ठीक है
कब लगेगा
तो उसके बाद अपना 32 हो जाएगा
रिमाइंडर रिमाइंडर
ठीक है तो नाम मैं अपन
डिवाइड बाय टाइम क्योंकि इसको ओपन लगाते
हैं पर क्योंकि यह पॉइंट में वैल्यू दिखा
देगा
देखो पीछे की क्लासेस इंपॉर्टेंट है गैस
तो अगर जैसे 123 में से ये अपना स्कोर
डिवाइड करेंगे तो अपना रिजल्ट आएगा
इतना भी बड़ा नंबर लेकर ओपन कर सकते हैं
अब रिमाइंडर अपना वेरिएबल है जिसको मैं ए
रही है
क्या 12 हो जाएगा
ठीक है तो अभी अपना यह जो नमक का वैल्यू
है
अगर अपन इसको डिवाइड करेंगे
तो अपना रिमाइंडर
आएगा
थ्री थ्री इन 10
प्लस
रिमाइंडर
पॉइंट करके
तो यहां पर अपना यह 320
प्लस वन 391
हो जाएगी
करेंगे अपने इसको रिवर्स में
क्वेश्चन नहीं चलेगा
ठीक है ना तो इसके अंदर अपुन को मां लो
कोई चीज चेक करनी है की वहां पर कोई फाइल
एक्जिस्ट कर रही है की नहीं
ठीक है तो उसके लिए अपन यहां पर सिंपल सा
लिखेंगे
दाल दूंगा जैसे
बात को
सही कहा नहीं है
क्योंकि जैसे मैंने आप लोगों को बताया था
की यह पंजाबी उसे करते हैं
अपन तो यहां पर उसे करो नहीं तो फिर ये
वाला उसे करो तो मैं यहां पर डबल स्ट्रेस
उसे कर लेट हूं हर जगह पर
ताकि वह किसी भी चीज सीक्वेंस की तरह
देता है
तो ऐसा ही यह वॉइस मॉडल राहत है अगर अपन
चाहे की अपन को फेल उधानी है तो अपन आस
मॉडल की थ्रू फाइल उदा भी सकते हैं जैसे
मैं यहां पर ओशोद रिमूव भी डन
और यहां पर मैं अपना फाइल का नाम लिख डन
जैसे
एयरपोर्ट
हो गया है
कुछ भी नहीं है यहां पर थी वह चली गई है
यहां से उड़ गई
सिस्टम
वह सिस्टम क्या करेगा ना सिस्टम का
टर्मिनल खोलेगा खोलना के बाद मैं अपना
जो कमांड है वह कमांडो
कर देगा ठीक है
खत्म हो गया इसलिए मैं इसको नॉर्मल क्रोम
के अंदर ही करूंगा नब लिख के
खुला गया यहां लिखना हूं पाइथन
तो यहां पर यह मेरा यह आईपी कनफ्लिक्ट
खुला गया है
पूरा का पूरा
ऐसे और भी मौजूद होते हैं रिक्वेस्ट मॉडल
होता है और भी होते हैं
तो इन मोडल के बड़े में अपन ढंग से अपन
कवि के हिसाब से देखते हैं की अपना
प्रोजेक्ट की क्या दिखतेवायरमेंट है उसे
रिटायरमेंट के हिसाब से अपन को क्या चाहिए
की भी लैंग्वेज वगैरा बना सकते हैं यह सब
रोज के लाइब्रेरी बनी हुई है तो अगर अपन
को कोई भी लाइब्रेरी के बड़े में जानना है
कुछ भी करना है तो अपना
गूगल पर जाना यहां पर
यहां पर जितनी
मिलेगी आप लोगों को ये दिखे रहा है
सिंगल कमांड से
अभी मैं कम करता हूं यह देखो
रहते हैं
जो कम के उसके जैसे लेटेस्ट
अब देखो क्लास की स्टार्टिंग स्टार्टिंग
में मैंने जब इंस्टॉलेशन के वक्त में आपको
बताया था की हम इंस्टॉलेशन करोगे तो नीचे
एक
बॉक्स आता है
तू पास करेगी कुछ लिखा हुआ राहत है वहां
पर उसको मैंने चेक करने को कहा था
उसे पर टिक करने को मैंने कहा था वो इससे
टिकने वादा था की मैं यहां पर कहानी पर भी
यहां पर लिखूं पे इंस्टॉल अपना
तो यहां पर
कुछ पहले से इंस्टॉल है
अपना कोई भी अगर इंस्टॉल करने का है तो बस
इंस्टॉल
साइबर सिक्योरिटी के लिंकन पेज पर ए जाओगे
ठीक है
इसके अंदर दाल दो
अगर नहीं आता है तो आप कोई बात नहीं आप
टेलीग्राम पे भी बता सकते हो हमको
टेलीग्राम का सब कुछ आपको इस वीडियो को
डिस्क्रिप्शन में मिल जाएगा
वह चीज क्या है तो यह दो आपको उम्र के जो
होम में बैठो आपका टास्क है जो आपको जाकर
जो भी पता करते हो वो चीज के बड़े में
जाकर आपको हमारे लिंकन की पेज पर और पोस्ट
के कमेंट्स के अंदर आपको दाल देने का है
तो आज के लिए बस इतना ही
थैंक यू गैस अच्छा लगा तो एक अपना रिव्यू
छोड़ जो यहां पर अपना
कमेंट्स के अंदर
है आपको कोई इंप्रूवमेंट चाहिए कैसे चाहिए
वो भी बता दो अपना अभी तक वह सोचती रखना
पड़ेगा
टेलीग्राम के अंदर टेलीग्राम पर मैं राहत
हूं उधर
देंगे दो कर लेंगे बड़ा रहेगा तो एक ही
करेंगे ऐसे क्वेश्चन पेपर वाले की बात कर
दी थी तो वो अपना एक ही हो पाएगा उसको
थोड़ा समझने में टाइम लगेगा
परसों के बाद आपको मेरी आवाज देखने की
जरूर नहीं पड़ेगी जब तक आप लोग का कल नहीं
किया ऐसा ये भी सीखने का वो भी सीखने का
है तब तक
थैंक यू गैस और हैव एन गुड दे गुड नाइट
टाटा बाय बाय स्वीट ड्रीम्स